hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray now we made our
way into the cafeteria under some odd
circumstances we seem to have been
misguided by someone who I don't think
they are who they say they are but all
that aside we've got oodles and
Kaboodle's of materials with which to
craft more bullets out of so I'm
definitely going to do that and I'm
actually going to get more 9-millimeter
bullets because those proved especially
useful against those things that were
mind-controlling absolutely everything
and you guys even said there was sort of
this sort of like a Typhon power that
you can have that might be able to
interrupt that and I don't know what
that might be but I'm gonna find out
very soon so anyway thank you skillet
that was insightful information for my
everyday life so I think we've already
gotten everything in here and now comes
the sad news that we have to uh we have
to go tell Danielle about Abigail but
what's weird is Abigail seems to have
been dragged in here she her head didn't
blow up rad didn't blow up so she wasn't
mind controlled by the thing outside
she's just kind of maybe murdered by
that guy who ran away mysteriously and I
don't know about that too much and I
still don't know why this guy was no no
I won't fight again I don't know why is
he so paranoid
why is he paranoid what makes him run
away from me I don't get it maybe I
finally saw his crimes or something in
the fact that he's not what Poe okay
don't throw a tantrum now here your top
there right there okay alright
weirdo so we need to go to the fitness
center because we need to go to the
fitness center window
we're a certain someone
oh my inventories full alright before we
do that we got to drop off our inventory
over here well for a certain someone
finds out about me don't know what the
hell's going on there excusa me to
zhilie why I don't get why he's so
paranoid
we need to get rid of this this uh we oh
that's right we'll Mitchell's tracking
bracelet because that was not will
Mitchell but in all that doesn't matter
we got all this food that I need to get
rid of too because I I like having food
on hand don't get me wrong but having
this much food it's just absolutely
excessive and I've got so many of these
EMP charges I'm never gonna use all them
cuz so many of the oh my god I've got
disrupter batteries out there with Zombo
and I'm never gonna use the disruptor am
i I don't even have that bound to a
quick bar you know what I'll give it a
try before I go about disassembling it
but that is that is a boatload of
materials and I'm gonna hold onto very
nicely so all right we look to be good
here I'm going to get rid of Danielle
shows cuz she's not here anymore
and I think it's time to say goodbye to
sylvain Bellamy I'm sorry it's just I
got a spare that tiny bit of inventory
space alright shove us key give it a
good thank you
alright come on give em all alright so
now that we got that let's skedaddle on
way we don't want to waste any time here
we don't want to scare will Mitchell
again do we how to ski the [ __ ] was oh
[ __ ] was that
da [ __ ] was her alright whatever we need
to go to the fitness center winter which
is over here by the pool I'm shocked
that she wasn't Oh what
what where are you out there why hello
was there a certain way I suppose knock
on this without room hi hello hi hello
Morgan
yeah me if you're here then Abby didn't
make it did she
sure I don't nothing more than I can do
for you right now but look be careful
there's someone else in crew quarters
pretending to be the cook his tracking
bracelets from psychotronics but the ID
doesn't make any sense he I think he's
the one that killed Abby if you can make
sure he doesn't get off the station I'll
see what else I can do to help from out
here for as long as I can okay come back
come back inside whenever you feel like
it Danielle all right I don't know what
you're doing out there anyway but okay
all right just tired okay so basically
my assumptions have been answered here
we'll Michelini who he says he is but
that does that mean that I just kill him
I guess anyway I got Daniel shows voice
I could have just talked to her what if
I had done that from the beginning what
if I just won't be wooed on that [ __ ]
women on finding cheese show you've got
what you need to get into deep storage
uh-huh why is caleb Thorne so important
over there I don't even know I don't
even know where this guy was oh hi
no no I won't fight what should I fight
you I mean this guy killed an untold
number of people and this guy was going
mad just causing these guys to blow up
like am i oh man this is like a moral
choice am i justified in killing this
guy
in the face of everyone else that died
does he deserve to live is he even going
to live now that he's out in the open
and why did he suddenly just run and why
did he why is he an impostor of being
the cook I don't get it there's
something else here
I feel terrible just killing him out of
cold blood but for what he's done does
he deserve death uh I just have a funny
feeling that there's something else
going on here that I don't know I never
feel good doing an execution Oh
Oh
well got that objective done I don't
feel good about any of that ah I don't
at all
why was he impersonating will Mitchell
who I obviously saw as someone else in
the in the in the messages that he left
behind I don't know but it looks like my
dirty work here is done it's time for me
to go to deep storage and audio no if
Daniel Cho would want to get a message
back I'll check my objective list just
to see but yeah I don't think that's the
way it's just done huh
additionally I have plenty of neuromas
to be able to get these gun upgrades
finally which is good because then I'm
gonna be able to actually do these
things a little bit better than I have
been and not have to spend so much on
Typhon stuff because I still don't know
if I want to give up my humanity like
that and I've got oh I've got so many of
these I'll obviously firepower is
definitely one of those you get one of
these bad boys magazine capacity oh yeah
get the accuracy up there oh it's all
good let's get the old shoddy show oh
yeah hell yeah give me those upgrades Oh
double damage oh you know I want that oh
yes please
Oh reload speed you know it's true all
right so we got all those that's fully
upgraded we got two left for the glue
gun which is my other favorite baby oh
yeah this is double up the
incapacitation rate because that's
that's really all we really want out of
that - 2500 so anyway we got glue we got
shaadi we got pistol so we're ready to
go so let's continue on here but man of
all the places that I've been throughout
gaming like you know you always remember
those environments that leave a lasting
impression and from one standpoint the
cat like the the crew cabin wasn't too
much distinguished ibly different
visually from the rest of the entire
place but just leaving a lasting
impression of all those people in their
last moments to the very last moment
in agonizing suffering knowing their
fate that awaited them well oh that's
was that always there before oh oh we
got incoming
I hear that engineer is not friendly I
see you you want try me
okay reload this bad boy before I go
engaging you Oh
okay one down where's the other one guys
nowhere
Oh what the hell whoo whoo hey you
thought you can do that to me lewb
all right let me get a Wampus whoa whoa
what's up hey these guys giving me
now wham okay there we go boom that
didn't go as well as I'd planned but
beggars can't be choosers oh oh
that it really only needs two now that's
actually awesome hope wham bam thank you
ma'am the cafeteria from 12 to 2 p.m. is
this really the time upgrade for today's
menu uh-huh
all right sure whatever you say all
right I need to get my health back up
because I also need to give her Maya my
room my super hair there we go then that
should be enough to keep me going and
then a couple cans of food and I'm good
to go
this time though I can be a little bit
better about it what is that or what I
did what I died did I see electro Jesus
just rise up a wise oh hi what the [ __ ]
and fat you stay right there
oh my god oh my god yeah holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
stupid lemmas little
oh whoa whoa whoa let me just look at
the research here just a second
nightmare the Typhoon's response to an
anomaly in their ecology something
that's like them but isn't me only
purpose seems to be to hunt me down
seems unstoppable uh so Wow
literally he's saying this particular
Typhon is only here to [ __ ] my day up
Wow okay so what do I do about that okay
it went away thankfully I'm not sure why
or how that a collaborator I don't need
that right now
okay you are god you're big Oh we'll
take fans in the middle yo hey buddy hi
buddy hi buddy
shut up ski wool electrostatic first - I
like the sound of that
can you go away please and got him out
of this [ __ ] no no no no no ow
got it I'm out of bullets
I'm out of glue bam-bam-bam-bam-bam-bam
ow [ __ ] hell this guy's an [ __ ]
well not that that's not gonna do any
good there we go huh
Frick a dick all right good night I also
forgot about my sigh hello can you just
seal me up please
so nightmare wizard what does that timer
mean is that mean later your feedback
will be invaluable yeah he's on the
lookout for me
oh no that a new version of the Moose
man oh the nightmare is freaking fast to
[Music]
your moose man friend is in a completely
different game holdings alrighty then he
is a little bit sassy today
I'm thinking that I just need to wait
out this timer and going out there would
be a mistake so I'm gonna make that
mistake and go out there right now whoa
whoa what the Franky Dickie oh hi ow
okay all right that's an option - you
can do that hey medical operator can you
can you kitty all right you know that
medical operation just got blown to [ __ ]
in back literally got blown to [ __ ] and
back get a little that in your place
hello
come on this is see me Oh No oh ho you
fall you fall down you go Foreman
oh no I'm so sad for you where'd your
body go give me your goodies don't run
away from me don't hide him there we go
all right so it's almost time for the
nightmare to evade or killed it I wasn't
gonna kill that thing it's a majestic
piece uh that key Kurt Stillson that's
okay yeah this medical operator took one
right to the face hoo-boy
yeah I don't know how I would have been
able to kill bad anyway so I can get
down to deep storage now secret cray
what does that even mean I mean I assume
it means secret crate but I guess I'll
go there and find out about the secret
Cray hey
hey hey come on
we don't oh Jesus
since when are you able to oh it's a
medical operator that's bankrupt no no
stop that you frickin do I'm just gonna
blast us get out of you
get blasted you freaking [ __ ] think
you can just do that to me and not heal
me first
freaking Boosh hey she gave me a medkit
common courtesy I suppose so what is
going on here oh I need to use his Q
because I don't hello hello oh wait no
I'm back to where I am what do you mean
secret creep Oh secret crate is in
another area I don't even need to worry
about that
screw that okay it's on to deep storage
which is just on the other side here
eventually I'm gonna undo the damage to
go down that way but not just yet I just
don't have time to do that so I'm gonna
go straight for oh hey can you not do
that and then I'll repair you because
that's annoying all right there we go
then my job is Baron do I have a key
code for here no engineer can you fix me
up
whoa okay thank you
what am I looking at here what are you
ah greater mimic okay
oops sorry that one was supposed to be
scanned and I didn't let it happen no my
bed oh whoa no whoa whoa buddy whoa
buddy whoa nope
keep trying to keep trying dude this man
we're [ __ ] morning oh so dead are you
come here ah ow he who did whoa
what's up alright fine man I'm not a
qualified technician what are you
talking about it to repair the junction
back there I did it pro bono even I did
it pro bono
how did it pro everything oh alright
so the last of those guys alright looks
like it okay so deep storage I still
can't get up here because I don't have
Alex's thing but I can go to deep
storage shooting hello it's me
you see that's the other thing weird
weird thing that guy didn't even know
who I was
I freaking run this place and he didn't
know who I was
that is bizarre voice identification
required please repeat the following
words prospective auspicious an
auspicious laconic MA
but I sounded a little robotic to me but
then again the guys saying it did place
it's easy to get through there when they
give you a prompt for the password if
anyone could do that then that doesn't
make it very secure now does it I don't
even know what would be in deep storage
that they would need to guard that
heavily oh well about to find out anyway
let's do this hmm Alex was are you what
I have to lock you in this time when I
dressed you're arming key it was to keep
you from making a huge mistake it's too
late to stick our heads in the sand
we're committed now you should be safe
in deep storage when everything is ready
or made in my office yeah she'll be
saved
Bailey I'm on your side hi there's got
yourself
you don't know that huh whoa Jimmy
whoa hook deep storage
you tell us one has a subconscious hope
that's where you uh hang on I'm in the
middle of something I'm just gonna okay
I died I didn't even pay attention to my
goddamn health fair are you know what
I'm not gonna do that
ah I'm gonna take a mulligan on that one
and I'm just gonna not engage everybody
out there by flinging flaming explosive
can endures she's bet they can let's not
do that
oh hey you see me whoop
off too late for you sorry not sorry at
all okay so we gotta get through here
without disturbing a Big Bertha who's
gonna be blasting out over there anytime
soon a point will that kill that mimic
I'm not sure though point oh you're
still alive aria you're a scam paint
yeah but we got a terminal over here
that we can check the email of so let me
do that all right mean a con day is a
nice guy and who can blame him for
trying to get off corrective wanting a
real desk instead of a card table he
sits out there all by himself with
nothing to do I feel sorry for him you
should try to be nicer to him I don't
like mean people Wow greetings
adventurers okay whatever then freakin
treasure hunt make sure to let the new
guy in four zero six six okay I don't
know where that's gonna be but there's
also something down here that I can
sneak through which seems like a much
better idea than what I was doing
charging headlong and getting blown in
the ass uh-oh
that didn't go very far at all well all
right that dog
that sounds bad yep that's bad I'm just
gonna keep sneaking I'm the sneakiest oh
I'm so sneaky oh I'm so sneaky why do
you have a turret remote manipulation
what is remote manipulation and how do I
get that every dark map dad moves
through the station's country here
redundant backup servers are stored in
modules that eject in the event of a
catastrophic failure oh the fact that
they haven't yet is telling of Alex's
refusal to face reality oh hey hey none
of that none of that none of that
oh okay so so what do I do
do I just kind of skedaddle on out of
here is that what I'm gonna go for it oh
oh I can't get in there can I nope oh oh
hi
oh well [ __ ]
I walked by an exploding blue tea and it
got me all excluded that's no good all
right let's try that again a little less
suck this time so I went down a dead-end
is my problem there okay good the big
guy didn't notice that kerfuffle there
big guys just completely blind deaf and
dumb okay good to know
so I got to get into the central
repository but I don't have access to
that gosh darn thing but I can get that
turret up and running
only I can just grab it whoa okay are
you at just grab it
I'm just gonna grab it place it repair
it
oh it's stolen oh my god it just stole
it
oh it just stole it
how is that fair tragedy is a recycler
charge oh boy oh boy
that do anything for us huh how about no
wave transmitter minimus
you're not stuck tough you're pretty
tough but you're not that tough boy
okay I can do this oh hey hey hey none
of that good god daddy ho and then I got
my turrets
that's so weird though it just it
literally just picked these things up
and then slapped them down now I can
repair them but man I just repaired it
just to feed it another turret no it's
goddamn ridiculous
okay so deploy down one facing that way
that one's already deployed I don't need
to hack him they're already on my side
oh the [ __ ] oh you are oh I see what the
deal is okay so the deal was they were
already they're already kind of hacked
and corrupted so I needed to get them
back on my side Jesus I need that power
I need that Typhon power because that is
that is way too good that is like
ridiculously good just to be able to
steal turrets away like that God if I
could just turn them on them but then of
course I afford the luxury of becoming
more alien myself which is probably not
gonna be a good thing but then if I can
hack them anyway so I guess it's okay it
all evens out in
and the Nigerian conclusive yeah
calibration request okay but at least I
did that at least I'm making a little
bit better progress about this so there
anyone here that has like a key card
that I can go through uh-oh
four zero six six you said Oh handy
dandy that hi I don't really have a job
for you but you could do hi whoa
why are you
okey-dokey then
death all around not a welcome sight no
matter where I go thank you thank you is
a Conde a Conde what they talked about
check in with chief show signed for
firearm get someone to watch security
booth windows shotgun shells is laying
about
mysterious music dinging off in the
background over there oh we got
radiation [ __ ] where's those electrical
arts coming from okay I don't see where
it is I'll take all these speech voice
conversion technology enables thins that
this systems to generate speech patterns
based on their source or entirely new
voices without the need for exhaustive
recordings pre-processing the quality of
the resulting voice depends on the
training data as well as the precision
of the conversation functions and
limitations in processing power well
it's good to know it immediately after I
did the thing that I just did least ammu
I'll go through the forest to death here
seems like a better war
seems like a better horse Oh God
so good I would have got here hey IV
Benin was snooping around my desk
looking for rats again he's so weird I
mean rats in space he was acting all big
city cop
newsflash no crime in orbit they need to
ship him home I don't think you should
talk to him
I don't like the way he looks at you and
make sure you get the fab plan I sent ya
you have to play the game with me
everybody's in you tiger is gonna be the
Huntress that the hunters yeah
Sandra's Bowl caster play with me babe
oh this sounds weird alright whatever
play with them babe I guess Oh
it's more of those things Oh can't move
this stuff I don't like it in there
alright whatever we're just gonna have
to get that one we get that that is way
above my hacking pay grade series I need
to get better in hacking I mean if I can
unlock the whoa kaboom alright whatever
I guess is fine if I can just get the
the plans unlocked again then I should
be better
come here you Flay me bastard you little
little little little it is sneaky I'm
stinky but I can't see it
Scottish ah I got you all right sound
okay I'm running out of uh unfortunately
I'm running out of doodle no that's not
what I wanted
kinetic blast all the way double ring
huh didn't mean to do that I'm gonna
actually get this a whoa hey oh you can
see me all the sudden whoa where to go
Oh God it was right on top holy [ __ ]
I didn't even notice that what are you
doing whoa how about you don't be a
frickin mimic Oh Frick you are I am out
of all its oh boy oh I wasn't even
watching god there's no warning there's
no like there's no like low health alert
and it's all the way in the bottom I'm
making excuses for my badness I've died
more this time than I have any other
moment but I am just completely out of
ammo and everything that I need whoa boy
get rid of these guys all right I'm
gonna get some choice shots on this guy
I'm not gonna waste save time I'm also
gonna throw EMP charges cuz I got so
many of them
what are you doing I'll [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] you
Oh get knocked down get down oh is that
gonna getcha what happens oh whoa I
noticed that time oh holy [ __ ] it's the
fiery ones they're the worst there's a
goddamn worst Jay Z they gave me like
nothing I mean nine millimeter bullets
that spin a hundred on him woof there's
got to be a better way okay uh talking
about personhood robotic fest simile of
himself named ransom huh so this is
talking about the weirdness of
personhood when there's artificial
things sending a kill signal to a
tracking bracelet is a violation of
Transtar policy do not deactivate the
tracking bracelet for any reason without
proper authorization Oh Oh a kill signal
I thought that meant like it's gonna
kill the person it was tracking okay
that's a little better and her bracelet
ID oh wait what sanic oh I don't have a
bracelet ID that I wanna kill well
that's weird that is super weird miss
show I wanted to remind you that we have
some sensitive information regarding the
volunteers and I'd like to make sure
it's secure I've also included
fabrication plans for some charges that
should transfer to storage let's see uh
doctor you I spoke to Lorenzo Calvino
and got no response so bringing the
matter to you there is evidence of an
unlicensed operator aboard Talos one if
so we might be risking another Transtar
North incident I want to ensure the
station's safety and make sure IT
protocols are enforced I doubt that
accident has any relevance to what
you're describing here if Lorenzo says
an investigation is unnecessary I
believe them
let's see doctor you and operator
follows a no manners command
Morgan may have built an unlicensed
model and if so it would have access to
station protocols
I'll make the matter to the board if I
have to but I want to have Morgan's
actions places station in jeopardy are
you certain of this if this operation
operator exists where would it be
are they talking about January because
they probably are because January
whatever they're talking about for this
Transtar north like incident that was
probably when an operator considered
itself alive and had proper
authorization to be able to do whatever
the hell it wanted to do and it probably
blew something up sky which is good or
bad
depending on how you look at it but I
see a lot of bad out of that okay where
did my I dumped a bunch of recycler
charges here I buy a bunch I mean to
they don't have that many of those I
keep tossing and I don't think the
recycler charge does any damage that
that I can see but I don't know I got
nothing better to do with my time what
did I just do
oh we're gonna recycler charge
fabrication station perfect I needed
more of those anyway get me junk over
there and let's get skedaddle dude
yeah the grenades I'm finding less and
less use maybe because I'm not doing it
right which will not be a surprise to me
okay I still gotta get the neuro much
[ __ ] out there get out of my face I get
it I get it I get it I get it I get it I
got it I got it okay we go
need more 9-millimeter I need more
shotgun shells definitely shotgun shells
are like my saving grace here they're my
main damage dealer as opposed to my
psychic abilities go go go go go
we got to make this I'm gonna make the
the recycler - oh that is cheap
oh there's really cheap Oh Frick up dude
oh yeah oh god what I would give to have
one of these in my home oh can you
imagine the [ __ ] out get in - oh my god
okay and then if they have a Sai hypo
okay I'm gonna make a couple of these
just because I mean I need to use a lot
more of my powers here and I probably
need to get more power soon which I'll
probably do medially after I get done
with
this one here okay so I got that I got
the recycler charge thing another
character she men oh it's Melinda shadow
corner oh I got another chipset okay all
right
Oh aggressor amp increases the damage of
all sigh attacks by small now he'll yell
do that that sounds good oh you know
what I'll do it I'll do it come on on do
this one dude good do that one okay
there were in there isn't leet si nice
so nice sorry I'm gonna disassemble this
bolt caster and then we're done all
right bull casts are done recycle moving
on literally do okay so we got what we
need here so we got a security key to
take us into that security station down
there which should quote unquote capital
should let us get into the next area
that we need to go to who is a damage
who's who's looking to get shot here
yeah don't do that your fix my stood up
for whatever it matters
thanks buddy you're a doll okay so if I
get into the security booth now then I
should be able to do everything I need
to do to get out of here oh thank you
for that
no [ __ ] you with that I don't need a
medical operator but I guess I'll give
one okay
you got that Oh what do we got here will
oh yes yes even though I just got done
dumping everything
EMP charge I guess that's gonna be good
Daniel show yeah I know Daniel show is
alive she's not in deep storage though
yeah she's in crew quarters that's what
it says looks like they got listed
absolutely everybody in here like they
got everybody but oddly enough the
Arboretum oh that's right in the
Arboretum they're still alive in there
Oh Oliver binoy my person oh no Alex's
personal assistant is dead power plant
oh man
weird weird weird okay take that shotgun
shells we already had that a long time
ago all right towels one safety reminder
circular respiratory it's a zero-gravity
environment whatever LA don't lock that
down give me in there you do delete it
oh okay I don't want to be here I don't
want to be here for this oh it's
official
typing material standing down okay all
right then you take care of those guys I
gotta get gone here
[Music]
it's gonna pop that bad boy boy yeah
pop this bad boy here and Wow there this
is just teeming just teeming with
corruption air or what do they call it
coral cool this gaming with cool so I
don't want to rock the boat just yet let
me read what's on here
husky oh oh boy
dr insulation please ensure all drives
meet Transtar compatibility and
encryption protocols prior to making
them available on the network okay so
i'm gonna mount the drive once I get it
down there I totally forget why I need
to do this I don't know why I need to go
to deep storage for this [ __ ] no not
today today chloral right there's so
much coral here there's so much there's
got it that means there's got to be a
weaver you oh my god that I found the
Weaver no you thought today oh boy
Oh what am I supposed to do about that
oh can I can I like hide or something
thank you I want to turn into that thing
right in front of me please give me I'm
[Music]
good to know it was me
oh you can't find me I my hidden yeah
okay all right whatever
that didn't help me at all [ __ ] off with
you alright so that is a deep nest no
let's not do that one we need that one
um look you're right on top of that
battle Oh like a quintuple kill babba
Jesus so many of you [ __ ]
how'd that get you guys picking [ __ ]
so there we go he's got mostly there's
still that Weaver down there and it's
like stupid the Weaver is just able to
generate those things willy-nilly
whenever they want
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay so I'm gonna try
to crack this Weaver in the face with an
explosive canister I don't know what
this is gonna do to it but so not that
that didn't hold ye did it even get
there oh okay something happened to it
whoa I'm scared or something but that
status was weird I've never seen that
before but that did something do it so
when that blew up that definitely did
something to it whoo hey all right so it
wasn't happy it was not happy about that
but okay but it did clear the path for
me to go get that hard drive which i
think is marginally more important than
trying to have an ego trip and fight
that bad boy so let's just go for the
hard drive and be done with that that we
can go and survive and fight another day
we have more Typhon material okay got
the backup Drive easy peasy hope it's
easy hope no one's coming after me
well okay alrighty then everything seems
to be hunky dunky hey no no no no no no
no not today not today wow that's a lot
of radiation and thankfully this is OK
from the explosion that just happened
flunkey okay you drive proceed to
install screen yeah mount that drive
unauthorized time
unauthorized how do you know what do you
know you know nothing good work I was
worried the drive might have been
damaged yeah the explosions might have
chose one station to download the
fabrication plan
ou can reconstruct your arming key cool
alright is there any other reason I need
to be in here no okay I'm out of here
oh hi Bob I sculpting okay Scott rope
deep okay ah that didn't what what what
what what
Wow hi why are these down no no you get
deployed you shoot him shoot him
Jim okay
I don't know why you weren't deployed
but that was weird
you should have been deployed there why
here you oh I see my other one
sure okay good where are you here you
one of these boxes No
all right whatever you say I'm gonna go
back up and you guys better not bother
me
yes good eataly do good Italy do alright
everything seems fine uh okay so I got
past those guys I can go to engineer
shows station and download my arming key
I almost entirely forgot the top that
was the whole point of that thing all
right
um arming key ha ha ha Alex you you you
locked me in the one place where I could
get what I needed
Tommy oh oh oh oh
Alex what'd you do
oh wait or did that do it did I get it I
can't tell if I got it or not
I'm gonna assume that I got it just
based on normal happenstance here I got
it right I got it all right whatever I
think I got right recycle that bad boy
morgen alex has you boxed in oh look
there's nothing I can do about the
lockdown from out here but I promised I
to help you so listen deep storage was
built with a series of data vault
modules that can be jettisoned from the
station
it's a redundant backup system that's
your way out
look at my workstation again I'm
exposing a utility that'll open up one
of the faults once you're in look for a
manual release then your ass space junk
like me okay well Danielle you know you
can get back on the station that is
still an option day it's not completely
gone charge plans okay on the treasure
on map Oh
oh but I don't really want that I don't
even know what even would that give you
what treasure could possibly be that
dire that it would help you survive in
this situation all right volt already
objected oh so that's how she got it uh
so I need to get the date of all be see
where the hell that is gonna go I can't
get in there can't even get in
confidential records so how am I
supposed to be able to get in this bad
boy can't crack through that I can't
leverage that it truly is a mystery one
that will never ever be solved for as
long as I live
so there wasn't anything else on her
terminal that I needed right yeah that's
tracking that's out of power all right
so that should have been it and that
means I gotta get out here somehow if I
can't get through here that I'm just
kind of lost to the winds aren't I
whoa hi ok hello Weaver good to see you
again why are you in there geez back
last three available
let me see you about a bat yeah I know I
know I know
ok so I have a remote manipulation ooh
that'd be nice aah machine mind would be
nice
Oh psycho shock would be nice oh that's
nice oh that's real nice let me see you
about my explosions 75 pushes away
anything ooh that's not bad oh that's
not bad either ooh oh oh that's so cool
but I like my explodey oh but my
explodey is mostly just for big boosting
damage bonkers but what I could do is I
could go for targeted damage instead oh
it's a tough call I'm gonna wait until
you guys give me some opinions about
that before I go committing my precious
neuro mods to that I know it's probably
very good for me but I'm still gonna
just I'm gonna hold off until I get
wiser words whispered in my ear oh I
know good job there you did absolutely
dick diddly nothin amounted of your
actions where did your corpse go I
smashed it into oblivion
all right fine then that's the way it's
gonna be all right so I got to find a
way to get into this date of all that's
the long and the short of it so either
there's a back way in because I'm
directly below it right now I don't know
how I would get in there there's gotta
be a secret way in this has got to be
right
do you see what I see uh-huh okay I see
a way to go up so if I can get up with
some choice glue splatter actually I
don't even need the glue splatter do I
hang on a second
oh I do a little bit now that Bell is
the opposite of what I wanted yeah but
if I get up here
ah so then I'm just a hop skip and a
jump from getting up to where I need to
be so there's got to be a way that I can
traverse all of this now ah
I hardly ever look up that's the thing
about this like these environments I
actually can just kind of like clamber
up wherever I want to go and I just I
constantly forget about it as a
possibility oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah okay
all right ooh
all right so if there's a way there's a
will there's a way and I think there's a
way and oh well shot boy what excuse me
from where I didn't expect there to be a
junction that was gonna zips at me I
didn't expect that I'm sorry oh god damn
it up down here oh god damn it
okay so apparently ah that's what the
dealio was oh okay alrighty then
I do did he do booty
[Applause]
hey he's easy I wish we weren't I used
to wish we weren't alone in the universe
no that's sad that's pretty sad okay so
I got to get into a pod no one knows who
did that or why no one knows none twas
were the wiser and I'm not entirely sure
what I'm supposed to be doing but oh you
you wouldn't be able to see me would you
no way yeah I'm a bother you I'm above
you I'm Way above whoa this Weaver is
damaged
has it been damaged by the I think it's
been damaged by the electrical
discharges
come on you're almost dead oh so close
now instead this thing's so close to
death I can kill this I know I can whoa
whoa whoa whoa that Weaver did not want
to die Typhon plasma that sounds
horrifying why do I have that in my bag
[Music]
brick you'd have killed me out of it so
piss no I don't think so so I got that
glue cannon oh hold over there whoa
don't go there look warp okay so we got
that we made it any air any other
supplies that we need to take before I
skedaddle on out of here and jettison
myself into space I don't think so alex
is dumb and a loser and I am oh oh oh
okay I thought that was body counts I
didn't know that was data they were
talking about okay so I need to go to
vault B as in boy Oh unpowered unpowered
what the oh I didn't even die didn't do
the thing ah I forgot that when I died I
didn't load up we're near to the wall so
here we go there we go not that one but
this one and skadoosh key okay time to
be blasted I'm ready as ready as I can
be I guess Oh join me
going here oh just need to push his
button well better say before I do that
and hold those key no regrets about
nothing Yolo
okay yeah
oh not as her a that is a lot less her a
than I had hoped thank you very much oh
I guess we're gonna be fine then just
gonna wake up in the middle of space
drift it out about ten thousand miles
away
cuz I got imagined Alice one is orbiting
something and if I just jettisoned away
with it and if I know anything about
physics I'd still be moving unless
whatever that was was that being pulled
back by gravity detected really no
nothing that interferes with memory
formation whoo I caught a flash of
something that looked like a hellscape
Oh someone put my helmet on for me how
lovely all righty then anyway that is
crazy but that is all the time that I
have for this episode here thank you
everybody so much for watching and
dealing with my patients on all those
deaths it was a little embarrassing but
I made it through nonetheless so thanks
again and as always and I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]